[Musique]
l'amopa association des membres de
l'ordre des palmes académiques a remis
le prix du concours défense et
illustration de la langue française ce
vendredi 19 juin dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source
alors nous avons remis des récompenses
de deux concours défense et illustration
date de la langue française et dans le
cadre de ce concours où là nous aurons
nous avons mis trois prix un prix de la
jeune poésie un prix de l'expression
écrite et un prix de la jeune nouvelle
un concours national qui a pour but de
promouvoir et de défendre la langue
française
cette année sur les 1955 participants à
la réunion l'amopa a primé 152 élèves
déjeunent ému et des parents très fiers
quand moi je ne comprends s'attendait
pas à ce que ça il le portait aussi
importante
c'est une fierté personnelle c'est c'est
valorisant et c'est vraiment plaisant de
pouvoir accompagner nos enfants sur ce
ce chemin de la réussite de l'engagement
de l'effort
ça fait toujours plaisir quand ils ont
une reconnaissance un prix voilà on est
très fiers en tant que maman que par
rencontre de plus cinq grands prix ont
été décernés
claire petit a reçu le coup de la
présidente du département pour son
notification écrite ma vision du futur
espace presse
t joyeuse et voilà j'aime être réglés
parce que j'avais écrit mais la demande
nassimah dindar président du département
et l'utilisateur président du conseil
départemental des jeunes souhaité être
présente à féliciter les lauréats pour
leur travail
si ce concours est possible c'est grâce
au talent de ces jeunes à leurs
potentialités qui s'exprime et grâce
également à leurs enseignants chefs
d'établissement à l'association l'avons
pas parce que sans le travail des
bénévoles leur application nous
n'aurions pas eu la possibilité d'avoir
cet après midi ses talents révélés
je souhaitais présente également parce
que c'est vrai que je suis une grande
passionnée d'écriture et je pense qu'il
est primordial pour nous jeunes que nous
sommes que nous apprenions dès notre
plus jeune âge a parlé au mieux la dans
la langue protestant à l'écrit qu'à
l'oral voilà je pense qu'il est qu'il
est primordial proulx parmi les 152
jeune primé une lycéenne et deux
collégiens se sont distingués au niveau
national
[Musique]